Andre Johnson is getting some beginners
ready for the mountain bike trail he's
dedicated his life to getting people
interested in sports
he and his team of 40 offered guided
tours for cyclists walkers climbers and
for skiers in the winter season but
Andres favorite discipline is mountain
biking one bin Isa God why do I like
beautiful fishing so much mainly because
of the many many sporting possibilities
here in particular the cycling
opportunities here you can cycle high
into the mountains
there's hilly terrain and relatively
flat ground around Hopkins a and for
guns a Lakes all kinds of possibilities
exist come and discover them with me
first of all we head up Tegel barrack
mountain bavarian king ludwig ii father
had a hunting lodge close to its summit
today visitors can ride a cable car to
the top you can see Shuang Gow and
fussen down in the valley below
so gets involved in the mystery animal
this is a medium hard mountain bike tour
half of the Tegel bag technically it's
not so challenging but you have to have
considerable stamina we're about an hour
away from fussen but when we reach the
top then we get the reward done a
volatile individual the goal is in sight
the roar cough hooter
it's a mountain cafe that's open all
year round
the reward is the spectacular view once
he almost a hook-up that I like it here
in the morning most when there's no one
else around
we're 1320 meters above sea level the
views of the Argo and tan Heim alps with
neuschwanstein and owens bungalow are
simply beautiful as ivanishin
and those views are best enjoyed with a
hearty snack a typically Bavarian
combination of sausage cheese and
pretzels for Andre's next recommendation
we head back to fussen it's a modest
sized town with a population of just
14000 the town lives from tourism
averaging more than 1 million overnight
stays per year
we make our way through the winding
alleys of the old town to one of the
town's important landmarks loosens high
palace
in there are three particularly
attractive castles and around fusun
everyone knows my ranch dined at home on
go we're in the inner courtyard of an
insider's tip the high palace of few
senses what I really like about it is
this courtyard with all its trompe
l'oeil painting it once mollify windows
and bay fronts almost all of them have
been created with paint alone this
decorative artwork dates back to the
15th century the building is even older
it was built in the 13th century for a
long time it was the summer residence of
the Augsburg bishops and from its tower
you can get the best view of the town we
can see our next destination shimmering
in the distance Lake forged right on the
lakeshore is the festival house Fuson
the musical venue is not the only reason
that andre has chosen the lake as one of
his tips
here the mathematical to finish were at
another one of my favorite places lake
for Ganzi we don't only have amazing
mountains but also Bavaria's biggest
reservoir there's not just an Alpine
feeling but also a bit of a seaside
feeling that's why I like coming here
that's a penny sigani yeah but he hasn't
come here to just sit around this is
perfect biking terrain a 32 kilometer
the lake with an amazing mountain
backdrop